PRESIDENT BIDEN IS IN FULL CAMPAIGN
SEASON.
HE WAS GIVING A SPEECH LAST
NIGHT TO DEMOCRATS, AND HE
POINTED OUT SOMETHING HAPPENS
FROM TIME TO DO TIME, HE POINTED
OUT WHAT HE CONSIDERS, I THINK,
THE HYPOCRISY OF REPUBLICANS
CLAIMING CREDIT THINGS THEY
DIDN'T VOTE FOR.
LISTEN.
>> WE ALSO PASSED ONCE IN A
GENERATION INVESTMENT IN OUR
NATION'S ROADS, HIGHWAYS,
BRIDGES, RAILROADS, PORTS,
AIRPORTS, WATER SYSTEMS, HIGH
SPEED INTERNET.
WE GOT A LITTLE HELP FROM
REPUBLICANS.
BUT NOT A LOT, BUT ENOUGH TO GET
IT PASSED.
BUT THE TRUTH IS, THERE ARE A
LOT MORE REPUBLICANS TAKING
CREDIT FOR THAT BILL THAN
ACTUALLY VOTED FOR IT.
I SEE THEM OUT THERE.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO BUILD THIS
NEW BRIDGE HERE.
WE'RE ALL FOR IT.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS NEW ROAD,
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
INTERNET THAT GOING TO BE ALL
THE WAY -- I LOVE THEM, MAN.
THEY AIN'T GOT NO SHAME.
>> THE PRESIDENT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, CHRIS.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT SHOWS YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT A GOOD RETAIL
POLITICIAN BIDEN IS.
THIS ISN'T UNPRECEDENTED.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE.
WHERE DEMOCRATS WILL VOTE
AGAINST SOMETHING IN CONGRESS
AND THEN IF THERE IS SOME
GOODIES BEING HANDED OUT,
THEY'LL TAKE CREDIT FOR IT ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
YOU SEE IT MORE OFTEN WITH
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO VOTE AGAINST
BIG SPENDING PROJECTS.
BUT THEN IF IT IS A DAM OR A
BRIDGE OR SOME OTHER PROJECT IN
THEIR DISTRICT, OR THEIR STATE,
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY, OH, YEAH,
THAT'S GREAT, AND THEY EVEN WANT
TO ANNOUNCE IT.
I'M SHOCKED THAT THERE IS
POLITICS GOING ON IN THE CITY.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S FAIR WHEN
THEY -- MAYBE IT IS NOT FAIR,
BUT PART OF THE ARGUMENT THAT
SOME LAWMAKERS WILL MAKE IS I
DIDN'T SUPPORT THE ENTIRE BILL,
I CAN SUPPORT SOME OF WHAT'S IN
IT, EVEN IF I DIDN'T VOTE FOR
IT?
IS THAT --
>> DOES IT PASS THE SMELL TEST?
>> WHAT THEY'RE BASICALLY SAYING
IS I DON'T SUPPORT ALL THE
FEDERAL SPENDING, BUT THIS IS SO
GREAT IN MY DISTRICT THAT I
WOULD HAVE VOTED JUST FOR THAT.
YOU KNOW, LOOK, IT IS POLITICS.
>> IT SURE IS.
CHRIS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE COUNTDOWN TO YOUR SHOW, OF
COURSE, IS ON.
SO THAT'S GREAT.
>> YES, TWO WEEKS FROM TODAY.
>> TWO WEEKS.
GET READY FOR IT.